you guys found do you think dating girls
in the church is better
like have you do you prefer girls that
are in church
i depend
i think it depends what you're looking
for
okay i
i think because i've dated a couple of
girls who are quite uh heavily christian
and they're very
traditional
which
brings a lot of things which are really
nice yeah i agree if you're at a certain
stage in your life where you know
um
i'm gonna say
they're
quite wifey material but if you're not
looking for a wife then it's not for you
at that point in your life i would say
at this point in time in these days and
times
generally churches
are no different from the streets
it's the same women that are in church
on a sunday we're just in the club on
the saturday
well that's why i was asking because i
was thinking i've heard a common
complaint from men about dating in the
church is that they're for the streets
too and they thought they're going to go
to church to find a wife and they just
find like
a 304 in sheep's clothing yeah you know
like
yeah that's true no as i'm saying
there's a say i i think that the women
in the church are the same nowadays to
say because the women that yeah they're
in the club they're in the bars
they're doing the same things that we're
doing but
i guess they have that in their head
they have that safety net of oh but i'm
going to church and you know i do all
this church stuff it's like well you did
have sex with tyrone last night forgive
me for that i'm saying like
you didn't have sex with last night
let's not die but if it makes you feel
better that you go in church on sunday
then so be it do you know what i mean so
i don't
you know when you say so you know you
said that you know some guy said about
the girls that go to church for the
streets are they
how old are these women they're younger
women are they older women like well
i've heard a couple different things um
i've heard a lot of like single mom
single mothers go to the church and they
become like born again virgins basically
i've in the church i was involved in
that
[Music]
it's like when you re-virginize
do they do an operation to put your
hymen back or like
what's that
it's like um
i mean it doesn't really make sense
okay it's just basically like
where the girls
regret the guys they slept with before
and then they want to make the new guy
wait for marriage for the girl basically
um yeah and i've seen i've seen girls
that this like worked for actually like
like there were girls that um in my
church like from home i wouldn't say
they were like three of like super you
know but
yeah but i've also seen girls like still
single in their like mid-thirties you
know because they're waiting
and you know what's so funny it's very
interesting you say that because
there's such a high concentration of
women in the church right
and there's not such a high
concentration of men in the church the
men that are in this church generally
are probably married
probably got probably god would be
really good men probably good men but so
they get snapped up quite quick by these
women you know what i mean so it's like
so then
what happens is it as i say in my
situation which is i've heard it a lot
of the time
um
the pastor will say obviously the man is
not in the church that you're seeing
because they have to go outside of the
church to get a man because there's none
in the church generally so when you go
outside that means you're not getting a
church guy
they tell the pastor and the pastor says
oh
he's not um of the same two people of
the same yoke or whatever the bible
verse is right you're not equally yoked
or whatever it was and so
the pastor
basically puts
you know a no and says no you can't do
that and it's like wow
imagine having like someone having that
much control over your life that that
happened to me
that that with my last boyfriend like i
um because he wasn't because okay when i
when i got baptized they like told me
because i grew up catholic and then i
like switched to a christian church
right and um
but then like they have to have you
re-baptized even though i what i don't
know but
i was like
no well no i wasn't
no no
but my last boyfriend wasn't um part of
the church but it was like one girl to
every three guys so i'm like what the
what else am i gonna do
like i'm not trying to fight over the
like five beta guys here
that's the thing right like church guys
no they're they're soft they women find
church guys quite softly yeah do would
you say that's true
yeah yeah yeah like they're quite square
and soft that's what i've heard women
say no okay this is usually how i'm
gonna i'm gonna tell you church dynamics
there's usually like one or two guys
that aren't like a couple right but all
the girls want him like i'm not trying
to fight him like
over a guy with like 10 other girls that
are all lined up you know yeah so
uh and he knows he's got to pick it a
bunch yeah
like he's like whoa i can just swag her
into church
when i could just date someone not in
the church like that seems a lot easier
but then your pastor will say that's the
wrong thing to do that's well that was
the thing i got a call it was like
really awkward this was such an awkward
phone conversation it wasn't from the
pastors from like another girl that i
did like bible study with at the time
and she like called me and was just like
well
he
he's not in the church and i'm like okay
so so what like what are you telling me
to do should i dump him but no i didn't
i just dated him anyway but
there's that pressure though
no it made me not want to go anymore
yeah because it's like awkward yeah
you know
but that's the thing about this is the
difference catholics we mind our own
business okay
christians are all up in each other's
business right because they look at it
as like a community thing the catholics
we would just get our communion on
sunday see no evil like
yeah like
i think i feel like
church does keep women single like that
yeah when you can control
like
who you're seeing from who you're not
seeing even though knowing that there's
not a bunch of men in the church that
these women can actually choose from
like what's a woman supposed to do i
have a question for the for the table
do you think
so these women who go to church and then
find jesus jesus later on in life
if they were already married and already
had the family unit that they wanted had
their husband that they wanted
do we think they would go back to the
church to be a born again virgin
no
so ultimately they're going back to the
church because they want to find a man
or they might yeah they might think he's
there
that's what that's my point that's
interesting yeah or they want the pastor
to
help them
find or choose someone yeah because i
never hear married women being like i'm
a born again virgin
church like
it's never it's never women who already
have you know maybe the the
relationships that they want
yeah what do you think yeah no i don't
know i hear that well that's what rolo
tomasi talks about that that's a female
mating strategy
yeah because you get you get more um you
get more resources from the guy and
commitment
for and you give less
so that's that's like the hard time that
i kind of have with it because i'm
wondering i have friends that have done
it right they like
i don't think they would have called
themselves born again virgin like that's
kind of kind of cheesy but they made
celibacy yeah yeah like but they made
the decision like with their now
husbands to like wait right
but
it's almost like
i hope you feel a little salty if i was
a guy and i knew you were like nailing
all these guys for free and then i have
to marry you like
it's just i mean like
thing is i you know i'm you know i i
coach men and women i mainly coach women
in dating and stuff but
if you're looking for a relationship you
do want to wait to have sex like if you
sleep with a guy straight away
he's way less likely to take you
seriously but i agree like if you're a
guy and this girl is kind of
saying she wants to wait and stuff oh
that's really nice because you think
she's you know you have this and we have
this tendency to think you know women
are pure pure yeah they're not human
right yeah yeah and then you find out
that she had a train right around like
two months ago yeah
but that's probably because she's taking
you seriously though
yo this is okay okay
maybe
before where if a girl
thinks a guy's like if she's attracted
to a guy right
but she but personality she's like nah
he's not good for long term but i'm
really attracted to him she'll probably
have sex with him willy nilly
but if there's a guy who she's attracted
to
and he has qualities that she's like wow
i think he'd be a great boyfriend then
she'll make him wait because she doesn't
want to [ __ ] her up is that true what
would you would you say i mean you're a
woman so you tell me
um i'm really awkward i've never slept
with someone like right away like and i
know everyone always calls me cap on
that but
um i would say with
[Music]
um
i don't know they call it and rolo
tomasi calls it like alpha and beta so
it's like there's like five guys that
girls are attracted to and i just
learned this so i'm probably gonna
butcher it but so it's like one is the
guy that's looks so that's like what
you're saying right like she'll just
sleep with him right away she's like
he's a bum he's good for nothing but
i'll just sleep with him
yeah because like god like he can't do
anything
then it's like the second one um is
what's the second one
um
the second one is like parental
investment so we'll meet you and think
like oh he would stick around and stay
with the kids and this is all like
biological so like the hot guy is like
the good genes right and the they call
it like the beta i i hate that for [ __ ]
yeah yeah and then there's like one
which i was told this is what like so
i'm going through the alpha fox
beta bugs you never heard that can i
explain it right now you've never heard
of that really no stop
okay sorry go on um so then this is the
one i was told that i look for the most
because torsh is the one you guys should
look look at torsh's channel because she
explains this better than i can but she
said that this is what i always talk
about so it's like um legacy so it's
like a guy that one's like not gonna
embarrass the family that's like um
i don't know that's like a hard worker
like that sort of thing like legacy um
and then the next one is parental
investment money so it's like income
and then i don't remember what the fifth
is
maybe someone in the chat is but i would
say like yeah if a girl
is just attracted like if they have
nothing else but looks then they'll
probably sleep with the guy sooner yeah